(pleurs)
- C'est la panique et l'effroi.
Après le séisme qui a réduit
ces maisons en décombres,
ces résidents transportent
un corps inanimé.
Les maisons, dont les murs
ont résisté, ne sont plus
pour autant habitables.
L'épicentre du séisme
d'une magnitude de 5,6
se situait à Cianjur,
à une centaine de kilomètres
de la capitale Jakarta.
Une région de deux millions
et demi de résidents.
FIONA DARBYSHIREDéDép. des
sciences de la Terre, UQAM
- Et le fait que c'était
directement en dessous
d'une région qui a
une polalation très dense
et aussi que c'était un séisme
qui était superficiel,
ça contribue à une secousse
qui est plus violente
quque la magnitude suggère.
- Les morts se comptent
par centaines. La majorité
sont des enfants.
"La maison s'est écroulée,
nous a ensevelis, raconte
cette résidente. J'ai déterré
deux de mes enfants,
j'en ai sept, et l'ud'd'eux
est toujours porté disparu."
Cet homme raconte qu'il a eu
à peine le temps de se sauver
avant que tout s'effondre.
Les secours s'organisent
tant bien que mal.
Les rues se transforment
en salle des uenences.
Devant l'ampleur de
la catastrophe, le chef
de l'administration de la ville
s'effondre en rmrmes.
"Les villages sont détruits et
nous avons besoin d'équipements
lourdsBeBeaucoup de routes sont
coupées."
À la tombée de la nuit,
ce médec s suture une plaie
éclairé par un téléphone
cellulaire. Les survivants
s'abritent car le risque
d'une réplique n'est pas écarté.
- Ça pourrait être un réplique
qui est suffisamment grande
pour causer pl d de dommages.
- L'onde a provoqué des
glissements de terrain
rendant impossible l'évacuation
de villages entiers
et faisant redouter
un bilan encore plus lourd.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montrl.